oh voyez le souvenir de ass Roy c'était
au Trianon si je me trompe pas cétait en
en 2013 et il y avait que des gars de la
h truc nous on arrivait et c'était dur
les mecs monter qu' s'en battait les
couilles genre vraiment rappé ilit comme
ça je me souviens d'un concert à cugot
dédicace au gens de cugot au lit tu
avait pleuré à la fin c'est une petite
ville à côté de Toulouse et je me
rappelle on était monté sur scène et moi
moi avais pleuré j'étais petit hein
j'avais genre 12 ans et j'étais allé
dans les loges je m'étais mis à pleurer
en mode il y avait personne ça ça
marchera jamais alors que j'étais petit
en fait c'était logique je le savais pas
c'est pas que des super concerts parfois
tu peux avoir des gros problèmes
techniques ou parfois tu as un public
qui est vraiment pas chaud ce soir là
sinon sinon les premières parties nous
on a fait beaucoup de premières parties
première partie de Mister youu en boîte
de nuit à Toulouse ouais je sais pas
pourquoi il nous avait appelé nous
c'était vraiment avant avant par C
c'était notre pote qui organisait avant
avant tout et on était là bon
franchement le public
plutôt cool gentil sauf que on finit et
on a le mec de la prte qui nous regarde
qui nous fait il est pas là encore ouais
et nous on est là mais on a et du coup
on a dû faire 1 2 3 4 son en plus moment
rejou les mêmes son parce qu'il nous
obligeait à rester sur scène à la fin
des sons les mecs commence à crier on ve
Mister You là première partie de 995 il
y a 10 ans je me fais moi ça serait le
le premier Stadium à Toulouse ouais où
vraiment ça paraissait impossible pour
nous c'était le but ultime il pleuvait
en plus il y avait une dimension un peu
mytholog logique il pleuvait des cordes
il y avait une ambiance de ouf le noir
venait de tomber sur la ville enfin
c'était vraiment exceptionnel quand on
parlait de faire le Stadium aux gens à
Toulouse à nos potes ou quoi c'était
même pas de la malveillance c'était tout
le monde rigolait même nous en mode ah
c'est impossible personne fera ça c'est
on disait un peu pour se marrer en
disant et et après on fera le stade et
tout et au final ça s'est fait quoi on
on fait une petite salle de 100
personnes puis on fait une de 300 puis
on fait une 2000 puis on fait un zénite
2 3 à un moment donné on avait fait
quatre Zénit d'affilé ouais et et j'ai
dit à j'ai dit au gars qui à Samuel qui
s'occupe de notre tournée je lui dis
mais il y a quoi après c zénite silence
il me fait le Stadium ou incroyable et à
partir de là l'histoire a commencé au
lycée je disais à tout le monde que je
connaissais ne en gros on était en
concert dans une petite salle à Montréal
tu te rappelles de ça non et je me suis
mis à rapper et je fixais sur quelqu'un
je me suis dit mais cette personne je la
connais et tout je me suis mis à rapper
à rapper et en fait c'était un mec de
mon école primaire que j'avais que
j'avais pas revu depuis euh depuis 20 20
ans il s'appelait Jonathan je me
rappelle et j'ai mis du teint et je
faisais que rapper je me suis dit et là
j'ai dit on arrête le concert d
excusez-moi il m'arrive un truc de ouf
excuse-moi est-ce que tu t'appelles
Jonathan il fait oui il est monté sur
scène il y a eu tout un délire un peu
émouvant parce que lui il était parti à
Montréal on avait plus de de contact
sinon il y a aussi des morceaux qui
partent et on voit certains certaines
personnes s'effondrer de pleur vraiment
le moyen et du coup on on se rend compte
que cette chanson là elle a déclenché
quelque chose elle a été très importante
dans leur vie force le destin on est pas
on devient
un truc un peu ouf qui nous est arrivé
c'est qu'on était en concert à La
Réunion et je reçois un message sur
WhatsApp en mode frérot est-ce que tu es
là c'est Karim et je dis Karim quoi
Karim qui et il me dit Karim Benzema on
s'est retrouvé à accueillir Karim
Benzema il était sur le côté de scène
parce qu'il pouvait pas aller dans la
foule logiquement et et on voyait Karim
Benzema tout le long du concert alors
qu'on était en train de rapper sur l'île
de la Réunion s'y attendait pas et c'est
ce jour là où il y a eu le plus de
problèmes techniques en plus qu'on a
jamais eu dans notre vie le jour où il y
avait Karim mais à chaque fois qu'il y a
des qu' y a des mecs qui pèsent qui
viennent nous voir en berc ou quoi il y
a toujours une galère ou voulais être
dans d' des milliers de personnes
jusqu'à même les stadiums les premiers
stadiums moi j'avais beaucoup de stress
parce qu'ils annonçaient la pluie ils
annonçaient une pluie de fou et j'avais
peur que ça soit annulé ou qu'il a des
problèmes des gens qui se blessent et
tout ça que ça gâche tout donc c'était
ce premier Stadium qui a été le moment
le plus stressant pour moi c'est souvent
des trucs extérieurs en fait quand tu as
pas la quand tu as pas la main sur la
ben du coup la météo c'est logique tu as
pas la main sur la technique forcément
des gens qui se pié on a toujours peur
de qu' qu' a un truc un peu grave donc
ouais c'est plus des trucs qui sont hors
de notre portée qui sont
stressants c'est difficile parce que
c'est c'est pas la même ambiance là on a
repris la tournée par les petites salles
avant de démarrer les éites ça m'a fait
un bien de fou j'ai adoré on a beaucoup
improvisé on a parlé avec des gens on a
fait monter des gens il y avait un côté
plus rot que j'aimais beaucoup mais au
bout d'un moment ça me manqué les
grandes salles et maintenant que
j'arrive au milieu de ma tournée zénite
ça me remanque déjà les petites salles
quoi mais je pense philosophiquement je
je vais répondre qu'on est plus petite
salles parce que pas de grandes salles
sans les petites on est obligé de passer
par là et c'est quand tu es bon dans une
petite salle ça peut te faire arriver
dans les grandes donc dans par l'ordre
des choses et poétiquement les petites
salles sont plus importantes dans la vie
d'un artiste ouais les concerts où il y
a plus de monde sur scène que dans le
public moi je suis complètement
schizophrène avec ça moi je préfère les
n concert toi tu préfères les zénites ah
oui les gens viennent pour te voir il y
a plein de Festiv o les gens connaissent
pas bien les paroles ça se voit qu'ils
attendent le groupe d'après non mais les
festival il fait beau il y a plein
d'autres artistes festival en tant que
en tant qu' humain mais en tant
qu'artiste ouais je sais pas dans
l'expérience humaine les festivals c'est
ça tu mais sinon les concerts c'est plus
d'ambiance pour nous moi c'est pareil au
bout d'un moment les zénites je me dis
ah [__] vivement les festivals ça va
être fou et pendant les festivals je me
dis ah vivement les Zénit çai le me bah
c'est un peu le propre de l'humain on
veut toujours ce qu'on a pas au final
c'est
beau c'est Oli le meilleur sur scène
sans hésiter sans équivoque on a deux
styles différents je pense Oli arrête
mant tu es le meilleur sur scène regardz
les commentaires ils vous diront c'est
pas grave olit c'est vraiment le il a un
côté très il a une énergie débordante il
est jamais fatigué il est toujours chaud
donc c'est vraiment lui le côté ambiance
met en l'air c'est lui qui est qui va
être le moteur quoi et moi je veux être
un peu plus capitaine du bateau à
regarder que tout se passe bien à gérer
les musiciens à me rappeler du morceau
d'après à ça peut arriver au lit des
fois de me dire c'est quoi là après
c'est quoi là tout le monde soit fan de
rap avant que ça devienne à la mode le
morceau dernière qu'on a fait
le dernier morceau de notre
concert on l'a vraiment fait en pensant
au concert quand on l'a fait en studio
et effectivement quand on l'envoie c'est
les morceaux comme ça qui sont vraiment
patates qui sont tout droit quand tuas
un gros benger quoi qu'on en dise ça
retourne une foule quand les gens en
plus connaissent le morceau et tout il y
a peu de chance de faire mieux c'est le
moment où il y a les confettis c'est le
moment où on envoie les ballons sur le
public les gros moments quand même comme
ça d'ambiance de bordel ça reste mes
moments
préférés j'aime bien les salles à
l'inverse de flow j'aime bien les
salalles qui transpirent un peu
d'histoire tu sais qui sont un peu qui
sont un peu sales sans faire de jeu de
mot mais qui sont les sal sal tu les
sales sales tu sais qui sont un peu tu
sens qu'il y a eu des groupes de rock où
les loges elles sont un peu un peu
défoncé tu as des stickers tu sens qu'il
y a une âme flow et tout l'inverse moi
j'aime l'inverse ma salle préférée là ça
faire vraiment mec qui se la pète c'est
le Madison Square Garden à à New York on
a vu on a eu la chance de beaucoup de
show là-bas ahouis c'est incroyable
c'est grand c'est clean c'est propre
après bon c'est les États-Unis donc ça
nous fait rêver là on est allé voir
Drake en concert je me suis dit il avait
pas raconté qu'il avait rencontré Drake
encore c'est bizar voir Drake à New York
cet été tu été invité par j'étais invité
par par Drake ok non mais en vrai
c'était incroyable le Lesch les show
américains de Drake et cetera je pense
aussi c'est parce qu'on est français on
est habitué moi je suis pas d'accord
avec toi
ça j'ai rien à envier aux États-Unis en
terme de salle non on a des belles
salles ici même le son est moins bon que
que quand tu vas au berc et tout
complètement j'ai préféré le concert de
Drake à Bercy donc voilà tu dis de la
merde tu mens à brut je me contredis
c'est aussi ça la vie au-delà d'être un
artiste c'est ça la vie parfois on dit
quelque chose on dit l'inverse on sait
pas vraiment ce qu'on pense on n'est pas
tous des robots
[Musique]
binaire
Allah